as new challenges to abortion rights
make headlines nationwide we're learning
for the very first time the identity of
the child at the center of roe v wade
that's the landmark supreme court case
that secured a woman's legal right to
have an abortion back in 1970 norma
mccorvey filed a lawsuit under the name
jane rowe asking to end her pregnancy
now she gave birth before the final
court decision the child known as the
roe baby was never publicly identified
until now her name is shelly thornton
she is sharing her story with journalist
joshua prager for his upcoming book the
family row an american story the
atlantic magazine released an excerpt
from the book this morning thornton
described her complicated history with
her birth mother and the burden this
secret has been she is the youngest of
mccorvey's three daughters melissa mills
is the oldest jan crawford spoke with
melissa mills in an interview you'll see
first on cbs mornings
you know that's one thing i think most
people when you think about roe versus
wade
people don't think about who roe is and
and your mom never had an abortion she
never had an abortion
no she had she had shelly before the
abortion law passed
[Music]
yeah quite a bit before i think
and
[Music]
they didn't even call her
mom didn't even know that the abortion
law had passed they didn't even include
her on any of that so she really
she wasn't involved in harley and they
didn't want her to be they said she
really wasn't the
the type of person that they needed
for even though they used her case that
she didn't present well she didn't
present well she was kind of a rough
talker
but you know jane roe means
so many different things to different
people to different people what does
norma mccorvey mean to you
it's my mom
we'll have more of melissa mills first
tv interview tomorrow morning the author
of the family row joshua prager will
join us live on monday